e.t had the exclusive backstage position
throughout the entire show
who you know do it better
i high five diddy moments after the mass
singer kanye west made a surprise
appearance to present his lifetime
achievement award while on stage kanye
also made light of ex kim kardashian he
inspired so many of my choices my wife
choices
and here we are thanks for that puff
hey baby girl kim this one is for you
meanwhile diddy paid tribute to his ex
kim porter who he'll be missing forever
since her sudden loss in 2018 from
pneumonia i just missed kim y'all
kim's son quincy brown reacted to the
tribute alongside diddy's son king combs
that just meant a lot you know i was
crying up there just from being proud
pop's been waiting for this moment for
such a long time and he went crazy
though he did go crazy
[Applause]
and twitter went wild when diddy thanked
ex-girlfriend cassie cassie for holding
me down in the dark time diddy did not
shout out current girlfriend young miami
who held a go poppy sign in the crowd
yeah shout out to diddy it's about him
tonight in prairie he getting a lifetime
achievement award
on stage mary j blige little kim busta
rhymes and jodeci all took part in
diddy's epic 13-minute tribute
performance
to be here helping him celebrate man is
everything to the world
that was the original
influence that gave us
swag that we could possess now
another surprise appearance
mimi took the award show stage for the
first time in over three years alongside
bt best new artist lotto allow me
and brandy unleashed a drop the mic
rapping debut with jack harlow
first of all i can't believe what just
happened
that's right i'm so thankful to jack
because he gave me this great
opportunity to like be a rapper like
i've had a rap dream for years don't
call me brandy no more coming down and
everybody was like
everybody just wants to hear you sing or
don't do rap but i'm like i love rap
will we get more rap from you in the
future clearly the world wants more i'm
asking you to can you look at the camera
because this is what i can use for
management okay you said this is on
e-tape we need more rap from brandy
right i'm gonna get that in in writing
did you see i'm acting a mess right now
[Music]
beyonce's protege chloe bailey gave a
show-stopping performance with a lap
dance while younger sis halle cheered
her on hallie has two big movie remakes
coming out next year the little mermaid
and the color purple i've been filming
the color purple i'm supposed to be
wrapped this next week oh my gosh i
pinch myself every day on that set
because you know to be a part of such a
historic film that we all known growing
up it's like wow what have you heard
about little mermaid i've seen little
clips
and i just i cried the other day i don't
understand how this is happening how
this is me and i just it's very
overwhelming and i get really emotional
when talking about it
just tell me is it happening tell you
know what we want you know we want black
bond well you know we want that no
you're not still on that no i'm dead on
it because we've done we're doing luther
that's what we're doing luther coming
soon watch that yes idris elba still
shooting down our double 07 dreams but
we will get to see him on the big screen
as british murder detective john luther
based on the bbc series some more movie
news girls trip two is a go
you know what it's gonna be better than
the first one really yeah where y'all
going you can't do girls trip too if
you're not gonna top yourself we're not
going back to new orleans okay we're
going somewhere bigger and better
and speaking of bigger billy porter gave
shoulder pads a whole new meaning i
caught him backstage right before he was
about to perform i'm gonna go on danger
in a minute y'all got to come on
look at that my ear things yes it's not
this my ear things you know no but what
is it
what are those where are you going
seventeen-year-old blackish star and
mini mogul marseille martin proved she's
all grown up rocking dolce and gabbana
she took home the bet young stars award
what is it like when people reacted to
like oh my god you're so grown i
i honestly usually don't have words to
explain it you know i i bet it's super
crazy for the aunties and everyone out
there that's been watching me for so
long i'm pushing t tonight me
host taraji p henson who was fantastic
gave us an epic parade of fashion
rocking 12 different looks i'm bringing
the energy
i'm bringing love and joy
[Music]